well denise many people are seeking the
outdoors for comfort and healing from
the pandemic that boost
is reflecting in money for the local
wildlife and even generating a hashtag
responsible recreation now according to
the nevada department of wildlife they
claim a surge in visitors from around
the state
is up 25 percent during the first week
five weeks
of 2021 now this means more revenue for
wildlife
recreational activities more hikers
campers hunters and bird watchers
means great news for the enhancement of
the conservation of local wildlife
state officials say hunting licenses
have also gone up
12 percent and fishing licenses 25
percent
last year nevadans are seeking and
finding
the benefits of nature at unprecedented
levels
the funding generated by their interest
enhances conservation
and provides some of the highest
economic returns
residents who head outdoors and seek
nevada's recreational resources are
doing so with their families according
to officials while at the same time
creating values in the state's future
money generated from residents seeking
the outdoors are helping local economies
especially those
in rural locations that are particularly
dependent on outdoor
recreation now state officials say
outdoor recreation based
license sales are the main source for
funding for wildlife conservation
activities
right here in the state of nevada
increased funding goes directly to
enhancing
the conservation christian castle is 8
news now